foreign
father was a restaurant owner my father
was a restaurant owner my name is
Vincent Yao Lim I'm a chef content
creator and restaurant owner
owning and running a Chinese restaurant
is one of the hardest and most valuable
things I think you can do
when we first arrived in Australia my
dad opened a Chinese restaurant I would
go there every single day to help him
out that was my way to spend time with
him and slowly I developed my love for
cooking
at the age of 15 I was able to use a wok
to cook and to serve customers now I'm
running a hundred seed of Chinese
restaurant
the hard work that I saw my dad put into
Chinese food makes me feel really proud
proud that I was lucky enough to learn
from my master
when I tell people that I'm a Chef
cooking Chinese food I want people to
Value it the same way that I do
so what is the value of Chinese food
is it the taste
is it the hard work and the training or
is it the dishes history and the
Nostalgia makes us feel
to me it is all of those things
but being in the restaurant industry I
can tell you the most obvious value of
food
and that is the price at which we choose
to set it at
the perception of Chinese food is that
it is indulgent yet cheap
but the value of Chinese food is so much
more than that
there is no formal culinary school to
train to be a Chinese chef and after the
pandemic there was a shortage of Chinese
chefs in Australia
now the cost of ingredients labor
and demand for Chinese food is high the
amount of skill required to cook the
first dish that I ever learned doesn't
match up to the price
the first dish that I ever learned to
cook was the fried rice
fried rice is the easiest dish to cook
but also the hardest dish to get right
I actually wasn't allowed to serve
customers until I got this dish right
the oil goes into the wok first
but only when the wok is hot enough
the egg goes in next
this creates a non-stick coating
for when the Rice hits the Hot Wok
[Music]
from experience you can tell when the
rice is too wet or if the wok is too hot
or too cold
all these small factors will create a
different end result
if the rice is too wet
you lose the Smoky aromatic flavor
but if the rice is too dry you're
basically eating Pebbles
[Music]
now we add a little bit of yum yum
now we add the cooked meats and
vegetables
I'm tossing it to combine the flavors of
the meat and vegetables with the rice
even if we were to remove all the meats
and vegetables
your eyes should still have all the
flavor
[Music]
from years of experience I can tell you
the difference between a good fried rice
just from the field and from the smell
without even having to take a bite
[Applause]
[Music]
and I thought
I thought that was enough
but I realized cooking with one Wok was
way too slow
so I took the knowledge from my dad and
taught myself the Dual walk cooking
technique
using two Ox took up two different
dishes at the same time
this requires coordination
organization and years of training
what makes it harder is the combination
of dishes coming up next
they have endless possibilities ciao men
sizzling garlic prawns egg foo young
when one is cooking the other is served
when the other is cooking the next is
served
the goal is that no matter the
combination all the dishes get to the
table at the same time
people expect this in a Chinese
restaurant
people expect variety
in a western restaurant you open the
menu there's 20 items
when I first started I had 300.
in a western restaurant
you can often judge the food by the
decor
the plating of the dishes or even by the
number of different forks for each
course
but in a Chinese restaurant it's a
little bit different you can often judge
it by things like the kids sitting on
the first table doing their homework
that's when you know a Chinese
restaurant will have amazing food
[Applause]
[Music]
I was that kid
so a lot of us Chinese immigrants who
started our own restaurants the
restaurant isn't just a business it's
part of our lives
we eat almost three meals a day there
and often we just use our homes as a
place to sleep
we dedicate Our Lives to these
restaurants and to making delicious food
in Chinese cooking we use a lot of
strong flavors
like ginger garlic chilies and even
shrimp paste
the different flavors I think are why
people like Chinese food
because every bite is different and you
never really get bored
by flavors flavors also built with the
tools we use when you use a wok you get
Wok hay or known as breath of the Dragon
is the reason why noodles and rice
always taste better at a restaurant than
when you try to cook it at home
walk hay is the combustion of oils in
the air that make that Smoky aromatic
flavor
but while K also tastes like nostalgia
growing up in Malaysia the kitchens are
outside just like this
you can smell every ingredient that goes
into the wok
the air is thick with humidity and the
fragrances of the food they linger
around so much longer
those memories they become nostalgic
the sense of home is what I feel when I
Taste Chinese while cooking
Nostalgia is what makes a good dish
taste 10 times better and that much more
valuable
but the value of Chinese food is often
compared to fast food quick and cheap
although we've spent years developing
skills to cook faster Chinese food isn't
fast food
it requires skills Mastery of
ingredients and nostalgia
in 2017
my dad passed away
I looked up to him
he was my best friend
when he passed away
I realized
I realized my passion of cooking dishes
from my childhood
I was working out as a chef at an
airline's first class Lounge at the time
but I didn't have any memories of the
dishes I was cooking
I wanted to feel closer to my dad
so I quit I dropped out of University on
my last semester
I hopped onto a plane and I flew over
here to Sydney
and I took over the restaurant that I
owned today
I wanted to record everything that my
dad taught me
so I shared onto social media
it went viral hundreds of millions of
views a lot of people related to the
recipes that I was cooking because it
was what they grew up eating with their
parents
I remember this one fried rice you made
I was eight years old at the time
it was the first time I recalled my dad
stepping into the kitchen cooking
he made this fried rice
with Spam Seafood peas
and a little bit of dark soy sauce
it was a little bit salty but it was the
best fried rice salad I've ever had
I cook and I've always cooked because it
was a way to connect with my dad
it was something that we shared
cooking represents all the hard work and
memories that we had learning the art
mastering the skills and understanding
the history of Chinese food
to me the value of Chinese food is so
much more than the prices you pay at my
restaurant
so the next time you visit a Chinese
restaurant just remember
it's not just a plate of fried rice
it's so much more than that
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]